promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur le 6 novembre 2023 à 11h25 précise
car figurez-vous que depuis cette date
les femmes travaillent gratuitement et
ce jusqu'à la fin de l'année alors une
date évidemment symbolique relayée par
la lettre d'information féministes les
glorieuses qui se base sur l'écart
salarial rapporté au nombre de jours
ouvrés et cette année les femmes ont
gagné 15,4 % de moins que les hommes
contre 15,8 % en 2022 un chiffre quasi
stable donc qui n'a d'ailleurs presque
pas bougé hein depuis que cette
opération de communication a été lancée
il y a 8 ans mais un chiffre à
relativisé car il ne prend pas en compte
les différences salariales à poste et à
tant de travail égal or selon ces
critères nous dit LC et bien les femmes
gagnent en fait 5,3 % de moins que les
hommes dans le secteur privé voilà prix
cité c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite sur Public
Sénat promixité vous a été présenté par
NG acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle